>> what? Murk's room looking like a murder >> Where's
she at? >> Who did it? Who did it? >> Who did it?
>> Nelly destroyed her room.
>> Who did it?
>> Sam, I want Lupa gone right now. I'm firing on her.
I will.
>> You will be asked to leave and now I'm going to have
the police. I'm going to have the security come and remove you
from the house. I told >> it was her dead mom. Supposedly
wrong. Okay. She said it was her dead mom. her dead mom gave
it to her. Here's the problem. Rick's mom's not dead. So, like,
I don't know if she just totally made this up. >> The only
reason I let Zena beat the me was to help Darius in his court
case. When else did I get my
>> Anyway, uh we'll see. I'm closing everything. I'm closing
everything. We're focusing up. Okay, it's it's time.
It's time. It's time. It's time. This is the start of from this
morning. We're going to run it from this morning. Okay.
>> Sam goes live this morning and he runs down the drama
from the day before. Maybe he'll tell us what happened with him
and Peggy. >> Okay, guys. Okay, so last night,
uh, let's do a little recap of yesterday.
A lot happened.
Yes, a lot happened yesterday. Um, we had a Wes and
>> # let Peggy
>> situation where Merk touched Wes's belly with the leg
of her selfie stick and Wes freaked out and um ripped the uh
ripped the tripod out of her hand and kind of like launched launched
everything to the floor. And then we had uh a Nelly and Murk
blowout where And then we had um a
Nelly and Merc fight like um Merk was in her room. Nelly came
to antagonize her. She came in the room. They bang the door backwards
and forwards for a bit. Nelly went into the room. Uh M stood
up, grabbed a bottle of uh beer out of Nelly's hands and poured
it all over
Merk just keeps pouring drinks on grabbed the ball, smashed it
on the floor, and knocked Merk's phone out of her hand. And then
I separated the two. Nelly went into Merk's bathroom and used
all of her like cleaning products
and um and put her toothbrush up her arm. Put Merc's toothbrush
up.
>> I missed that. What? uh like cleaning products and um
and put her toothbrush up her arm. Put Merc's toothbrush up her
>> That didn't happen. >> And
then MC lost her uh because all of her personal products had
been touched and she
went upstairs with >> no one cares. >> All of her
This event sucks. You should be jailed. >> All of her uh
sha shaving. All of her shaving
uh all of her all of her shaving f all of her shaving fo all
of her shower gels. All of her everything
everything uh what she poured on uh
she poured on um Nelly's's bed. So yeah, that happened.
Everything everything got destroyed. Uh
>> we watched that where MC emptied everything on the bed
like a psychopath. Then they all had that alcohol
and there's been a lot of deductions this morning which I'll
go through shortly with the housemates.
Um, and then this is what, bro, this is the story I I mean, for
me personally,
like the whole fighting and like um
pouring stuff on each other and all of that kind of stuff is
for me it's >> Hey Sam, you want me to put the cigarettes
inside the house now? You are a gay gay [__] and
I love beef.
dollar sign give credits
10,000. Nice. Um
>> he just took that guy's ability to TTS away, I think.
>> So, um so, so this is the the story lines that I like
like the things that I like that's going on in the house right
now are um I I like this merc and >> Hey, Sam Eddie is
in the chat. Hey, Sam Eddies is in the chat. I like Eddie. No,
he's not. Eddie's not in the chat, bro.
>> What's the plan, Nelly?
>> Nelly Wes. >> If somebody >> Hold on. Hold
on. Oh, this is literally the same [__]
>> Oh, I have to do safe stuff. That will >> So,
I believe this is Murk's room, right? I've seen MK laying in
this. Oh, maybe it's not. No, this is Yeah, Merk. Murk was getting
a massage in this bed. This has got to be MK's room, right? Brook's
the only person who could reach a t-shirt up here. >> Too
much money from you guys. >> What's your ideas? What are
we cooking up here? >> Chad is saying, "Pe on the bed."
>> That would be [__] hilarious. >> Take
a beer. >> Can you guys unlock the bedroom door? Can you
guys unlock the bedroom door and come downstairs? Unlock the
bedroom
>> Can you refund my TTS 3.8K? I don't know how to use
>> right now. >> I'm just filming.
>> Uh Merk's not happy. >> Uhoh.
Right. >> Everyone that >> Mer was like V5
V5
>> upstairs will be deducted 250. Everybody that's upstairs
will be deducted 250.
That's where
>> Nelly grabbed. Go back. >> Bedroom door. Can you
guys unlock the bedroom door? Go downstairs. Unlock the bedroom
door. >> Cuz yes, I know the story behind >> my 3.8K
don't know how to use. >> Yeah, she does. Grab that stuffed
animal thing. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I got it.
>> Key key event for later on. >> Everyone that's
upstairs will be deducted 250. Everybody that's upstairs will
be deducted 250.
That's Wes. That's Mike. That's Nelly.
Dude for my >> They've been calling Merc a rabid giraffe.
And unfortunately, that is just accurate in like every single
possible way. Like she's tall, she's gangly, she's awkward, she's
in your face, she has rabies. Okay. >> 250 for Wes, 250
for Nelly, 250 for everyone who's upstairs. Bring yourself
>> 15 for everyone. >> 250 for Luca for being upstairs.
250 for Luca being upstairs. Get downstairs. Go to the living
room.
>> For being upstairs, get downstairs. Go to the living
room. >> Are you not going to listen? >> No, you
just hit me. No, I didn't. We
>> Nelly uh Merk MC if you can go downstairs I can deal
with Nelly. M if you go downstairs I'll deal with Nelly. >> If
you can go downstairs I can deal with >> I want to make
sure my shit's not
>> All right. Just just >> your ass. >> No.
Don't beat anyone's
>> I'm going
this was moved. MC seems to have found this moved stuffed animal
and she goes I'm gonna beat her ass. I'mma beat her ass.
Okay, it's our first clue. Our >> Do not beat anybody's
ass. Oh my god. >> Do not beat anyone's ass. The stream's
just started.
>> Can you We not beat people's asses right
>> Hey. Um. Yo, M. Get the stairs.
Stop being a idiot. MC, get upstairs for
a $4 deduction for her.
Look at my
five times assault. >> Look at this. Just keep
the security.
One second.
>> Look at this.
>> You can go upstairs. You can go. You >> lost your
warm. Keep going. Just keep going.
>> Everybody stay downstairs.
Everybody stay downstairs.
>> Sam's in control, guys. Sam's in control. Okay, we're
going to watch Nelly comes in for a confession. I guess Sam has
cleverly muted the stream while Nelly is in here trying to do
a confessional thing like a [__] [__]
Hey, idiot. You muted the stream.
Sam. Sam. Hello. >> You're both going to leave the house
if you want. >> No, I do not care about this house. I'm
saying I just got >> somebody with TTS. Okay. Donate now.
Gay. Gay. Gay. Gay. I want >> Okay. Okay. If you want the
police to be involved, I can't stop you. But I'm I'm going to
have to ask I'm going to not even ask you. I'm going to have
the security come in and remove you from the >> I told
you you have 10 minutes to figure out what are we doing, sir?
>> I'm not going to I'm not going to sit I'm not going
to sit here when you're saying you're going to call the police
to the house. >> I said I will do it if you're not going
to remove the threat because there is a woman attacking me. If
you feel uncomfortable in the house, you're free to leave at
any time. >> No one's holding you. >> Leave the house.
The house is over. I'm telling you, I just got attacked and I
did not sign this on any contract that I'm going to have physical
harm. You understand what I'm saying? >> Yeah, but you
did sign in the contract that if you cause any losses to the
house, you will be responsible for them. >> What is the
loss on the house? >> If you call the police that the event
will be over. So then all of the fun >> Yeah. No, I will
I will just go to police and I will just report several harm,
several damage, injury.
Yes, but m >> both of you will leave the house. If you
leave the house and you're going to call the police, that that's
fine.
>> Uh, no. There's a No, the channel didn't get hit for
that channel got hit for the uh KY. >> Mer will also leave
the house and you guys can deal with it separately. But if the
house gets involved,
>> you don't understand. You don't understand, Sam. I'm
saying you we have some time to figure this out without me involving
police. I didn't say I'm calling police right now. You literally
the reason why you're in the diary room is because you said you're
going to call the police. You've got to stop with this instant
compulsive lying.
>> You literally
you did. You just said you're going to call the police if I don't
do something about it right now. And you said I didn't even say
I was going to call the police. >> This is like this is
like all
this is like
uh all of these people except for maybe Wes.
And Wes only doesn't compulsively lie. I feel like because Wes
just doesn't care. If Wes cared, I could almost believe he compulsively
lie. I think he just doesn't give a feel like all the rest of
these people will just like they'll say some and then they'll
get in trouble for it and they'll be like, I didn't say that.
No, no, I didn't say that. >> What are you saying? You
literally just said that. >> I will call police. I said
in 10 >> Exactly. And then you just told me now you didn't
even mention about calling the police. >> I did not say
I didn't mention Sam. I said I will call police in 10 minutes.
But I said, "You have 10 minutes to figure out this before that."
>> No, I have as long as I need to figure out this. If
you need to leave the house, you can leave the house. No one's
holding you hostage. I will take however long I need to figure
this out. It's my show, okay? If you don't like it, you're welcome
to leave at any point. Nelly, >> you think this is okay?
>> I I haven't said anything about it. I haven't said it's
okay. You're not giving me a chance. If you I've removed
MC from the situation. I've told her to stay in the room. I've
locked the door.
If you feel in danger at any point, you can walk out the door.
Okay, just so you know, we have security there. >> This
one took over guy is such a hater.
Such a hater and won't hop in the cord to defend his ideals.
Okay, it's very >> Why didn't security come when a girl
was attacking me? So, >> it was over in a second. Okay,
if you feel uncomfortable, if you don't feel safe in the house,
you can leave. I need to deal with this now. And you're just
slowing it down. You say you want it done in 10 minutes, just
throwing it down. Stop with the police talk. >> He's forcing
out of the house with this got armor. I know it's insane.
>> He's forcing Ellie out of the house. I do believe that
is the case. Okay, if we
seems that that is possibly almost entirely the case. Okay, guys.
How do I know that? Well, I know that because of the next clip
that's coming up. Okay,
give me a second. Give me a second. >> Are you leaving
the house? So, I just need to let the security know. >> Yeah.
Yeah. I'm going to bounce. But I >> Oh, this >> Oh,
dude. This is a brutal conversation. I watch this one as well,
>> bro. I don't think it's a rough >> conversation.
Replacements for this >> No, I have replacements coming
every day. Moxy's replacements coming. I I have another guy ready
to go in today if you leave. Like every >> I somebody told
me this guy's name. I forgot it from yesterday. Okay. But this
guy, this guy basically gets told by Sam that like, "Hey,
at least you got like free [__] paid for." And this
guy's like, "You didn't pay for any of my shit." [__]
you talking about? >> The house is continuing.
>> Yeah, let's uh Yeah, I'm going to leave, Sam, but if
you need help with that's fine. If not, I'm probably going to
head >> I'm glad you enjoyed your free flight here. Thanks
for hanging out for a couple of days. >> I didn't get a
free flight. I uh I bought my own flight. But yeah, >> I
mean, bro, I lost all the money on the flight that I paid for
you. >> You lost 400 bucks. Think you told me that I get
$200 or $300 an hour on KCIP. I'm getting four bucks an hour
on KCIP.
>> Eli, you know, you know, you know, you know KCIP fluctuates
up and down. >> My my KCIP is lower than it was when I
was in Miami. I was getting 27. >> Everyone's that's how
it goes. It goes up and it goes down. >> An hour
at 27. >> But okay, so you're you're
>> just totally gaslighting the guy. >> Leaving right
now. Okay. >> All right. I'm just going to let him know
you're walking out the curtain now. >> Love you, Sam. I
think you did a great >> Oh, he didn't even let the guy
finish telling him he did a great job. That's rough. What's up?
>> I just realized that guy is saying that his KCIP went
down over over $20
because of being in this house. Like the content of this house
lowered his KCIP.
I think what Sam might not have told anybody and what I know
is I believe that KCIP is actually regional. I think they updated
that and they said it's regional now. I'm pretty sure if you're
in North America you get way more money per hour than you get
in uh in Thailand.
>> That would make sense too. Okay. >> I think that's
the case. Like I'm pretty
>> are Thai people just
>> is Casey >> I think I think it's like anywhere
outside of North America you just make less money.
>> I think so if I'm not mistaken cuz there's like a bunch
of Spanish streamers in like Latin America and stuff and I think
they don't get paid anywhere near as much. >> Why would
they do it that way if the if like the language is English?
I would understand if it was being streamed in a different language,
but it's still streamed in English. >> I don't know. >> Cherry's
gonna talk. Make her speak into the mic. >> I'm so sorry.
Shut it down. >> I think that was sarcastic, actually.
But uh anyway, I think I'll just I'll set I think I should set
up a second mic. That would be a good idea. Let me see here.
I think this goes to show that while all IRL streamers are skits,
the best skits are not streamers. Sam Hyde knew to pick actual
freaks up off the street with zero fame and career. That's not
true. Those people were aspiring skitsos. They're just hungry
skitsos. You need hungry skitsos. Wes is despite how Wes looks.
Okay, he's not a hungry skitso. Mike Smalls Jr. not a hungry
skitso. Not even MC. None of these people are actually hungry
skitsos. Okay, you need somebody with like five viewers and they're
schizophrenic. Okay,
that's what you need. Why would they do it by region when you're
streaming uh and when you're streaming and not audience?
Uh, audience is probably harder. I'm guessing. I'm guessing.
I'm guessing. Uh, could be could be Harmony. I don't know how
they do it exactly. I think they announced it a while back. We'll
we'll I can try to find an article here. Okay. Sam has muted
once again instead of actually just letting these people talk
and yap at each other. Sam has muted once again.
Once again. Sam has muted like five minutes since he last muted.
Oh,
Sam Pepper, what are you doing?
>> Oh, well, here here's the guy leaving.
>> He's heading out. >> So, that guy is the first
guy down. >> has infinite plot armor.
>> It doesn't matter.
>> So, these guys complain for a little while. Murk has
plot armor. M has plot armor. What does Sam do? I think Sam might
want to prove that out. Okay.
>> Now he comes back in. >> I'm going to pack your
bags. I'm going to get the security come and take you out. Like
I said, I don't >> No, no. I said I don't want to. I said
I'm not going to deal with any of this legal stuff. You trying
to affect the house or anything like that. If you do want to
do that, you can do it. No, no. I told I told you if you mention
the police, if you do anything like that, you will be asked to
leave. And now I'm going to have the police I'm going to have
the security come and remove you from the house. I told you I
cannot have a liability in the house. On behalf of me and behalf
of my channel and the work that I put onto this, I am going to
remove you now from the house. >> Can I say something,
Sam? I'm not going to call police or do anything. I was >> You
just said two seconds ago you are on your phone speaking to your
lawyers. >> No, no, no, no, no. I texted your girlfriend.
Hey,
>> you said you're on your phone talking to your lawyers.
I said I'm texting my lawyer and I texted your girlfriend me
in time because I need a review of the contract because I signed
it without understanding what I signed into. So I need a review
asap because I I don't know maybe I can get kicked in this house
and I need to make sure that I will not happen. >> Is that
really you're calling your lawyers or you're texting your lawyer
because you think you signed a contract that says it's legal
to kill you in this
>> No, you said you're you're texting your lawyers. I don't
Nelly >> I couldn't care less. You can be in the house
or you can not be in the house. If you don't like it, if you
want lawyers, if you want the police, then leave. >> I
don't want police. I don't want >> If you want lawyers,
if you want the things, you read the contract. You signed the
contract. Your name was on it along with a witness along with
your passport number along with everything. You are a liability
to this house. You're a chronic liar and I'm not dealing with
it. >> I'm not dealing with it. >> Chill down, Sam.
Darling, chill down. Okay. Do you want to actually talk or you're
doing this? >> No. No, I don't want to torture you. I 100%
do not want to torture you. I need you to stop. I need you to
go up to the room and I need you to be quiet if you want me to.
>> I need you to help so I don't get in this house, Sam.
>> Okay. Okay. I'm I'm going to send the security in. Sorry.
I don't want you to be fearful of your life. I'm sending in the
security. You can just go. >> Thank you, Nelly. Thank you.
>> Good luck suing Sam Pepper in Thailand, by the way.
Or sorry, the Philippines.
Good luck. Okay, so she leaves. He's just texting the guy. I
don't know how he's going to text the guy. Does he not need Peggy
to tell the guy what to say or to talk to the guy? Am I crazy?
Or would Peggy not have to go and actually
talk to the security?
Wait, he's in Thailand. It says the Philippines here. This literally
says the Philippines. And the house is in Thailand. I'm pretty
sure he must be in the Philippines.
No, he's in Thailand. Okay, now they're fighting again. And it
is muted again. He has muted the stream once again as they're
evicting Nelly.
Do we need Wes's POV of these things so we can actually see what
the happening? Although he is trying to get a hold of security,
so it's possible he's just fighting with.
>> It is possible he's just fighting with
>> You don't want to hear it. You don't want to hear it.
You didn't want to hear it. You did not want to hear me. >> You
did not want to hear it.
If violence is not I will get killed in the house and nobody's
I need we need to make sure that >> Sam you got to get
a grip on the dude >> because I asked Sam before coming
will there be death
>> this is not already like funny if there is violence
I don't want to be here >> just keep
>> because he doesn't want to keep murder bro this is >> not
a single other person in the house has been violent besides murder
just so or unless it was in response to murder
Go off, baby. >> Get off the tracks again. If you're not
Sam's pulling only 500 people to the poll and these bodies on
Yeah, we
>> I do not understand why literally the whole house is
here against Mark and and I guess Sam's just going to defend
Mark no matter what. >> Surely that won't backfire on him.
Aligning himself with Mark, just only defending Mark. Surely
that'll work out in the long term.
>> There will be a death in this house. I don't [__]
up, but I'm just like
>> I can go there. >> I can't think I can't think
of a single thing that could possibly go wrong if you defend
and rely on Merc. Okay. Or your content.
>> Nobody can leave the room if you leave the room. That
will be a penalty.
I can't leave room. If you leave the room, there will be a penalty.
>> What did you say? >> You can't leave the room.
>> But how kicked me? Whatever. It doesn't >> I don't
think he's kicking you. >> You have a chance. He sure is.
He's coming for you because I >> I think he's bluffing.
>> Doesn't matter, bro. >> I tried to talk to him.
He just >> Don't fall for his answers. >> You're
a conclusive liar and he's lying. >> His name is Scam Pepper.
All right. Don't fall for a pass.
>> You good? You good? You good, Charlie? Gentlemen, hey
Sam, you cool. Just take a deep breath. >> You vibing.
>> How did they start it, bro?
I don't >> Nobody's scared of Sam. That's the thing. Nobody's
scared of Sam at all. They just don't respect him. He's getting
run. He's just getting run rough shot over. >> He needed
somebody there who's like on his side who would have like uh
You need a Jet Neptune, right? You need Jet Neptune in there
who's actually like interacting, controlling things. If you're
just sitting back, you never like nobody's scared of you. What?
What are you doing? >> Scared. The only thing wrong can't
handle another death on this platform. Dude, someone dies on
like once a week. I wouldn't be surprised. >> The only
thing I heard about cake before coming here was that somebody
died the same week and everybody in his crypto committee was
saying, "Don't go to the show because it's dangerous." >> Everybody
in the crypto community, by the way, >> and I came and
>> everybody in the community, by the way, kick them off.
Get a fresh cans. I'm I was thinking the same thing like one
week reset, right? >> One week reset. Get rid of all of
them. Brand new cast.
>> Evil Johnny Bravo. Are you saying there isn't somebody
capable of containing Murk? There's nobody above 5t tall. She
just like holds a drink above like 3 feet above their head and
pours it on them and they have to run. I guess that's how it
is. Okay. Merks realize that every single woman is when trying
to deal with her because she just holds a drink as high as she
can and pours it on their heads and they literally can't reach
the drink. Like it's over. >> And then I just keep repeating
it and the prize money never gets claimed by
>> It's like it's like 200 IQ. No one gets the prize money.
>> Oh god. Is he really Is he really thinking this already?
Oh, this guy's a [__]
There's no way he's like never get one week reset, right? One
week reset. Get rid of all of them. Brand new
>> There's no way he actually says it out loud
hours before doing it. That's crazy, bro.
What?
I didn't know this. I saw some of the clips from this. I didn't
know he actually did this. Yeah. Spoiler alert, the house ends
today. It all falls apart
and nobody wins. We're watching this whole thing go down in flames.
But I didn't realize like 4 hours before or 3 hours before it
actually ends. He says, "I'm going to actually just end it and
kick them all out and not give any money out." What the dude?
>> I just keep repeating it and the prize money never gets
claimed by anybody.
>> It's like a It's like a 200 IQ. No one gets the prize
money. >> They all go and we just get a new task. >> Dude,
Ice was looking for a way to get rid of this guy from Kick.
>> How would it not be easy for Ice Poseidon to just like
go to Eddie and be like, "Look, this guy's like scamming everybody
in your platform. He's running with like kick branding and he's
just going to scam these people out of their >> And every
time they me off new cast and we do it again.
>> And I [__] up.
>> I [__] up and I need to make sure I'm
>> Mike can stay. Mike can stay. Mike will carry through
to the new cast. Mike will stay. He'll carry through to the new
>> Everybody says that they are [__] Mark liability.
>> Sim said he was going to get a brand new cast for weekend.
>> He laughed with that one. >> Yeah. Like anyone's
going to come here after this, bro. What the [__]
Deducted $10,000 in 3 days. I'm sure >> everyone everyone
who asks is going to look and they'll make zero followers doing
this besides KCIP, right? >> Well, like I
>> Sam Hyde actually established the meta since season
3. You don't actually ever you don't ever actually pay anyone.
Why do people keep showing up?
>> Do you mind the beer beer that burnt in the smoking
area? Yeah,
last night.
>> Everyone should leave. It's going to play out great.
I don't know. Oh, I wish you lose.
>> I [__] with Eli so hard that just laugh.
>> Wes is like reading his chat who's telling him uh they're
relaying to him
>> amazing. So sweet like what?
>> I don't know. >> All right, hold on. Okay, apparently
a little bit later, Sam tries to fix things between Nelly and
Murk. Apparently, he he had not kicked Nelly yet. Nelly at this
point still not >> When Nelly enters the room, Nelly, sit
down on the right hand side of the room. On the chair on the
right hand side of the room, Nelly, sit down on the right hand
side of the room. On the chair on the right hand side of the
room. >> Okay. All right. Lock in here, Sam. Okay. Now,
fight to the death. No. No. >> How is How is Sam going
to resolve this conflict? He spent his entire life just stirring
[__] between people. How the [__] is
he going to resolve this conflict with the security dog? Why
did Sam hire actual children to be security for his event, too?
That's also weird. >> you two have both been antagonizing
each other for the last week,
>> and it's just getting so annoying, and I don't want
to deal with it anymore.
>> And it's just getting so annoying, and I don't want
So, I'm going to give you two both one more chance before I evict
both of you from the house.
>> I'm going to choose two individual rooms that you're
going to have to go into. And you're going to be isolated to
them rooms for 24 hours. You're not allowed to leave the room.
No one's allowed to enter your room. I will make sure you get
food and water.
>> Like, look at his instincts. I'm actually going to uh
I'm going to make sure that you guys don't do content at all
for the next 24 hours. Just you you just don't get to do any
content. You just go sit in your own rooms. Okay. Wow. And if
both of you can do that for 24 hours, not leave the room
not have anyone in your room
>> and behave,
then we will then we will continue
>> and whilst you're in the rooms, there's going to be
new rules made about aggression, about stirring people up and
trying to make people fight you. If you're trying to make people
fight you as well, you're going to be held
>> If you're trying to make people fight you as well, you're
going to be held
>> Is that like a small implication that Nelly was trying
to get Merk to fight her or cuz this Nelly person didn't seem
to be doing anywhere near as much as Mk was. There was that grabbing
Merk stuffed animal, which by the way, again, that was a key
moment. So, just remember that going forward. Okay. >> Do
you agree to doing this, >> Mark? Do you agree to doing
this?
Nelly, do you agree to doing this? >> Nelly, do you agree
to doing this?
>> Okay. Both go back to your rooms where you were just
in. Nelly, you go first.
>> And then go up in 3 minutes. >> You go first.
>> And then go up >> in 3 minutes. >> Just
wait a second. M, and then go up.
>> Go up. >> No. Oh my god. No streams would be crazy,
bro. I think no stream should be done. Two.
>> But let's see.
Yeah. Does >> that mean you have to like stay in your >> Yeah.
And not leave. H. >> What happened? What happened? >> Why
is his voice the worst thing ever? Uh, it's Sam Pepper. Okay.
He's got the Chav accent. It's [__]
>> You take You take a Thousand Dickers and Beckets, okay.
Over this guy right now. And I understand it. >> Get my
clothes. >> Uh, do you realize that she's not getting kicked
out, right?
>> I know she's not getting kicked out. >> So, I
need some to get a maid in my room, too, if he's thinking. Otherwise,
I'm doing what I said I'm going to do. That makes sense. Tell
Zan >> my my clothes are in a toilet to toilet and I need
a maid to come.
>> Entirely otherwise I'm going to do anything. So >> he's
making a new rule that if you antagonize someone, they hit you,
you get kicked, too. All right, this this show's dead.
>> This show's >> I literally can't even interact
with anyone.
I was talking about
I'm Sam. Sam, can you hear me? Sam Sam, I need to talk to you.
West is kind of like if you have Wes on a show like this, he's
kind of a force of nature.
You try to contain him, he will naturally fight against that.
Okay? You try to contain him, you try to like keep him from doing
his thing, he'll just turn against you and he'll just start on
everything you do. Right? That's where Sam's at now. No matter
what Sam does, Wes is going to say, "You're the show. You up.
You're you're up. It's over. It's over." Right? Sam's turned
Wes against him. Terrible mistake. walk out the door. >> Sam,
did you hear what I just said? Sam, >> ass fake game.
>> I don't want to fight that [__] I didn't
fight her yesterday. I didn't attack her the other day. I I didn't
let Sam make me go with some pandemic in a room because I knew
that's going to instigate. How do you say that? >> Wes
is such a cat. Karen >> Wes is the number one [__]
bottle of beer yesterday. >> Wes is the number one Karen.
Sam's up. He's continue to Wes when Wes is just back. Okay,
Sam,
you're not as good at as Wes is. All right, you're not going
to be as good at >> The whole stream's just watching you
and the security guard standing there watching the TV. You guys
can go. >> I mean, we'll watch them. Just move them from
the [__] toilet. >> Just go. Yeah, I'll tell
you if I need >> Doing this. >> Yeah. And then you
want cigarettes. Uh, three pack cigarettes and beer. And beer.
Yeah, she wants cigarettes and >> Okay, hold on. >> I'm
down to do whatever here. That's one >> Just try to respect
my
whatever I ask you for, too, because I respect you. You respect
me. >> I've got my next time stamp right now.
>> I'm
going to start skipping around a little bit. Okay.
>> Amazing. I
>> Mark's still sitting here with her stuffed animal.
Oh, West moment.
>> See, West versus I'm basically going to skip through
the West moments. Okay. W and Wes talk to Sam. >> What
the is this? >> Santa. Sammy. Sami.
>> Wes, you're being deducted $100. I told you you can
go and have a cigarette and that's it. I told you you can go
and have a cigarette. You had five minutes and that was it.
>> We're trying to find the lighter.
>> I don't care. You should have came down with the lighter.
I can't do anything about that. >> 10. You should have
came down with the lighter. I can't do anything about that. >> Okay.
Money. Eat my weird shrimp dick loser. I don't care. I'm not
going to [__] go back out. Wait for the [__]
Take another $100 for talking [__] about Eddie. [__]
you. Suck this. [__] you, S. [__] your
gay painting. [__] this. Suck the [__]
piece of [__] [__] You loser. You're
a [__] loser.
>> What's up,
>> W? I can
>> Oh, Russian Innovation. Let's go. She figured out the
toaster.
Is >> it working?
>> Sam, we're lining up in the house. >> Yeah, we
need cigarettes. It's banana paper. This stuff
will pass out.
>> Give us cigarettes, please. >> Yeah. Can we just
have
>> you boss here, please? You you pegged the [__]
out of Sam. He's a gay [__] You're this Chad sexy
beautiful girl, right? You mob the [__] out of Sam.
Sam's a
>> Peggy's just giving us the cigarettes. Peggy. Peggy.
>> So, if you're going to give us some sigs, oh, forget
it. Beautiful queen.
Just do whatever. I don't care. I'm just
chilling.
Oh, also I need some I need a microphone because my microphone
does not work.
>> Still looking around. They hang out in this room for
a little bit. >> I believe it's somewhere around here.
Okay. What is this? >> Skip to this time stamp right here.
>> M gets brought back down. Okay. Her room's open. >> Turn
ch. Oh, sorry. >> This this uh blonde girl comes in, throws
the stuffed animal at Merc.
Oh, no.
Why skip that? Did Peggy bring Sigs? I don't know. That's not
That's not a part of the time stamps. Okay, this is where kicks
off. All right,
the Russian woman, the blonde lady, she just went and grabbed
Murk's stuffed animal and tore it apart. If you don't remember,
that thing was pretty circular before. It was like stuffed, full
of, right?
It's been ripped apart.
Murk's room looking like a murder scene. >> Where she at?
>> Where she at? Who did it? Who did it? >> Who did
it? >> Oh, Nelly destroyed her room. >> Wait, who
did it? >> Sam, I want Lupa gone right now. I'm firing
on her. I will say
why you attack
Sam.
Why you not attack me?
So that stuffed animal apparently very important. All right.
She left. [__] >> So MC actually straight up
leaves the whole thing. Murk is Murk drops out. Okay, so apparently
it was her dead mom. Supposedly wrong. Okay, she said it was
her dead mom. Her dead mom gave it to her. Here's the problem.
Merk's mom's not dead.
So like, I don't know if she just totally made this up, but people
said that it was Murk's mom. like Merk's dead mom that gave it
to her. Apparently, she said this. Merk's mom is not dead.
So, I don't know where the this came from. I mean, I'm being
told by the premier Mercs that her mom's not dead. So, I don't
know if this is just totally made up. I don't know what the [__]
this was supposed to be.
I actually just have no idea.
But she straight up leaves over
>> All right. Luca pushed it over the edge.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Just walked out.
>> You're a [__]
>> You're such a [__] child. You saved
>> She did it so that she got kicked out.
>> So she was going to free. >> Why did Sam Pepper
retweet a clip saying that that was a gift left for her by a
dead relative then? I don't know. Maybe it's a different dead
relative. It's not her mom cuz people have been saying it's her
mom. Maybe it's a different red dead relative. Maybe it's a grandma.
Maybe it's an aunt. I have no
>> She just ripped up stuff in the room. I
>> Oh my god.
She just
>> Plant Dad, if you got an opinion on this, Plant Dad
watches a lot of this stuff. Plant Dad consumes more kick slop
than anybody I know. Plant Dad, is it Mer? Was it given to her
by Murk's mom? Because that's what Murk said. I I've heard Murk
said this. Did you see her say it?
Cuz I've not seen I see everybody saying Merk's mom's alive.
It can't possibly be from Murk's dead mom. Murk said that, but
no clue. I thought it was grandma.
I don't know, man.
>> She's there. She She should go outside. >> Uh,
yes. This would be the first thing I'd say. Evil Johnny Bravo
is I would never bring anything important to this house. A house
with Wes in it. That's a content house. No shot.
I wouldn't even even had to calculate with these other people.
Wes would use that for content eventually. Okay.
>> Yeah. I mean, >> she is a little horse. She she
she ripped the stuffing out of her.
>> It's really pop of loop to be honest with you.
>> But I mean, they're smart. >> That's the game.
I mean, loop cuta basically like her.
>> This is what MK told Sam for sympathy. I know 100% she
has she hasn't mentioned this toy before. It hasn't been in streams
before. Sam believes everything MK says and Merk talks her
like you know like a childhood toy that you like take to bed
every night. She like ripped it all up and like poured it all
over the room
>> which is kind of crazy.
You had to play the game. >> I know.
>> Uh is it
is it crazy? Cuz like didn't MK just go and like destroy a bunch
of other people's popular or property for no reason. Merc doesn't
show any concern or regard for other people's property. Why should
this person Why should the Russian lady Why should the Russian
lady give a [__] about anything MK has there? When
Merc goes and breaks other people's [__] pours like
their [__] bathroom all over their bed, right? Why
should anyone give a [__] about Merk's property when
Murk doesn't give a [__] about anyone else's property?
>> literally on Nelly's's clothes. Gross. That's gross.
>> Play game. Did you play game? >> You played the
game. >> But I mean, it's gone now.
I've deducted her
woman's train. >> She ran out of the house. >> And
every woman
who will come to this house, every woman will know what will
happen with with with her if she will did this.
>> You understand? Everyone woman who will come into this
house. >> It's so funny to me that you're doing all this
crazy [__] You have that makeup on.
Oh, so the Russian girl's makeup apparently got destroyed, which
you know, she's on stream all the time. >> Damage. Yeah,
I put damage. >> She's smarter than me. She's smarter than
me. She's smarter than me. >> But the thing is, it's like
I can't have them like destroying people's.
>> You know what I'm saying? >> Sam, you have spent
days defending M, destroying everybody else's. You idiot. You
gay.
You've defended everybody doing this. Why are you pretending
you don't defend everybody doing this?
>> Like it can't be a war of destroying people's [__]
>> That's what I don't like.
>> No, she
>> I feel like you can still hear Murk like she didn't
actually leave the house. She's like near a microphone. Every
once in a while I hear her crying.
Am I crazy? Everybody sit down in the living room or you will
be fined. Everybody sit down in the living room or you will be
fined. >> She will stay here.
>> Everybody sit down in the living room or you'll be fined.
Sit down in the living room or you'll be fined.
>> Jesus [__] idiot.
>> It's not It's not >> I mean they do do something
cuz they're going to be evicted eventually, you
>> I want to keep sure. I know. I know. >> Okay,
Merk's out, guys. Merk's out. Merk's out. Merk's out. Uh, let's
see.
Next time stamp. We go forward a little
This is the Russian girl coming to talk about what happened.
>> You want to talk about what happened? >> Oh, Riyle
has a theory that it's a toy Darius bought her. >> Well,
that's basically a dead relative
>> Um, no, it's just karma, bro. It's just karma. You know,
you was you saw all this situation every day. I told her I will
kick her from this house because
>> Oh, sure, sure, sure. Guys, this is this is absolutely
the case. Um, there's a supposed to be a $50,000 prize. Okay.
And Sam deducts from the prize whenever somebody up. So, yeah,
this he's doing fines on people's potential prize >> Did
very bad. She crash everything. And me too. Not only Nelly, right?
She scared me. She's scared to fight with me. And when I when
I uh did this with uh her toys,
uh first question first question mark was like who did it?
But I hold her uh I hold her her toys but first question was
who did it? Because she scared me. She really scared. She can
do damage only for and fight with Nelly.
This play this kick house. Okay, this is translating for you
guys a little bit. I think I'm understanding. She says Merc didn't
want to fight with her, even though the Russian girl obviously
had the emptied out emptied out husk of her stuffed animal. She
says, "Well, Merk asked who did it because she do not want to
fight me. She do not want to fight me. She is scared of me."
Okay. >> I
That's all. That's all happened. Nothing happened. Nothing happened.
It's lesson four for M understand
now she understand. >> Walk around and find out. >> Do
you know why Merc's upset and like she didn't attack you and
she just left the house? >> You know why? >> No.
Do you know why she didn't attack you and she just left the house
and doesn't want to be in there anymore? Because the toy the
toy that you destroyed was bought by a dead relative for her.
Someone who's not around. It's something that a dead relative
bought for her who's not here anymore. That's why she just left
the house.
Sam,
I understand
why I need think about her stuff like I can't damage or I can
broke her stuff or not. But she didn't think about like she didn't
think about me about nail stuff. She just >> What did she
do? What did she do to you,
>> What did she do to you?
She uh my my clothes my pam she uh how to say like put uh some
cream or on my pam and my cosmetic broken.
Uh
>> it's dark watch broken. >> My cosmet cosmetics.
I have a cosmetics. >> And she she broke my cosmetic.
>> Oh, like your makeup or something? >> Yeah, makeup.
Yeah, for makeup. That's That's That's too much. That's too much.
Of course, I didn't know about the to this toy toys, right? It's
very important for her. I didn't think it's just my emotional
just my emotional. She ruin all cigarettes all around me. It's
crazy to fight people when she when she
hand. That's crazy. Just crazy
go out. No, I don't want stay with her in this house. I don't
want. That's why >> maybe if Sam could enforce any rules
in this house, these people wouldn't have to take matters into
their own hands.
I told her I will kick from uh from I will kick you from this
house. I don't want sleep with with her in one house. I don't
want just reality project. Right. Right. He start doing he start
uh he start crush or everything. She's starting. She's starting.
Not me. Not daily. She's starting. She started this [__]
[__] uh [__] [__] [__]
[__] Like a [__]
this person okay?
Is she good? Is she Is she That's a rough pause frame, though.
Is she good, >> Yeah. Thanks. >> Okay. All right.
Oh, >> when you can go when you go up to the room, you
can let the rest of the housemates know um that any property
damage of anybody's property
um it's pouring something on it uh damaging it. Anything anything
um it >> Why are you making this rule after M's gone? You
>> It'll be an instant removal from the house from now
on. You understand, right? any damage in anybody's property,
you'll be removed from the house and any new contestants will
be told the same
>> Mhm. Okay. >> So, only me or other? >> No,
tell everybody upstairs. Go upstairs and tell them all. Okay.
Thank you. Bye. >> 30 minutes.
>> Okay. Just real quick thing after this. Apparently,
somebody wants me to watch this clip real quick.
>> Here's the thing. >> I don't know why this is
apparently a revelation. MC said she was doing this intentionally
back when it happened, right? You guys don't think that I can
defend myself. The only reason I let >> cannot penetrate
the powers of the bur. >> The only reason I let Zena beat
the out of me was to help Darius in his court case. When else
did I get my ass beat? I don't remember when.
>> But that whole Zena situation was literally to help
Darius.
But look, look where we are now. Look where we are now. He doesn't
even [__] talk to me. So I regret it. Honestly, I
should have let Zena put his ass in jail. We should have banded
together and play in jail
>> on hood.
>> Let me watch you from the corner of the room while I
camp. >> And everyone's like, "Haha, you got your Yeah,
that was the point. That was literally the point. That was the
goal.
>> Cuz
she has an assault charge. How's How's that going to look for
his court case? How's that going to look for her restraining
order against him? WTFW?"
>> But never again will I put my neck out for him ever.
Okay. Well, that's that's insane cope.
>> classic merc.
>> All right. All right. All right. We're moving from this.
All right. So, things cascade from here pretty fast.
>> Let's take a look. >> No. No. I don't care about
No, I don't care about
>> Yeah, just wait there. We're organizing for you to leave.
>> I would like Wes to put a shirt on. How about you go
yourself, Latutigious Gamer? Okay, Wes is not putting shirt on.
He explicitly didn't bring shirts with him. He didn't pack any
shirts.
>> Just wait. >> That's kind of a lie. He brought
one shirt on his back and then he tore it off upon entering the
house. >> Hey, we're organizing for you to please give
us some back then.
>> Okay. Can Can we go downstairs, bro? I'm starving like
a [__] >> Nobody can go downstairs.
take your stuff or go downstairs? >> I feel so hungry.
Santa literally just wants us to be miserable. He's such a [__]
[__] >> Ready to take your stuff or not? >> This
is why everyone leaves, [__]
>> Three of the five people that will have left will be
because your treatment
>> You're not letting people
>> dead mom thing, bro. We all have [__] important
things are
important people are joking >> just because our mother
doesn't mean you would do that why would you [__]
deal why don't you bring it here
>> if you guys could have controlled your
>> dude I
WSL Sam WSL Sam W Dude you can't [__] with Wes on
like this okay
Sam I feel like Sam's entire mistake here was just getting Wes
on his bad side or getting on Wes's bad side and just setting
Wes up to be like a [__] what do you call it? Like
a uh I don't know, a negative Nelly for the rest of the [__]
event, right? You got Wes on your side. He'll he'll get everybody
to be happy. He'll be funny. He'll be all chill. And now Wes
is just Dude, Sam just wants us Sam just wants us to be miserable.
Sam's going to kill this whole event. Sam's such a piece of
Do not get Wes on your bad side. Do not get West bad side. >> The
challenge would have started hours ago and you'd be eating.
>> I don't care.
>> Good. Good one, bro. You got us, Dad. Eat a
>> like downstairs. By the way, you two people want to
leave now. >> Yeah, but first
I'm waiting. Okay, I'm waiting. I'm waiting.
Yeah, I need to take my take my uh uh stuff from our room and
that's all.
>> you're leaving. Don't worry about it. Go get your
>> You can start packing your stuff now. You can start
packing your stuff. >> Don't worry about
your stuff now.
>> I'm scared. I'm scared, >> Sam. Tell them banan.
>> So, he's saying you can start packing your stuff. Get
the [__] out of
old stuff. Yeah, she's gone down.
>> Ah, okay. Let's hug
>> guys. So, I want I will follow you every
everyone I will follow in Instagram and we can we can collaboration
more. Babe,
>> she's crying apparently.
Are you okay?
[__] disgust.
>> Wait, how do they win this prize? Whoever stays the
longest. Yes. Whoever is there at the very end is supposed to
be the person who wins.
>> Can you come to the diary room, please?
>> don't cry.
>> can you I will I I will meet the end of the 30 days.
Okay. But that's only if there's if there's only one man standing,
that's the winner, right? If there's only one person laughing.
Fake crying. Fake crying. >> Bro, I had the speakers still
on and just said it in the room. [__] >> I
was waiting for you outside. Okay.
>> Don't cry. Don't cry. Don't cry. You >> She's
so adorable.
>> Oh my god, she's so adorable.
>> She's going to be alone. >> My queen. Hello. I
love you. Nice to meet you guys. Everyone, nice to meet
>> I don't want her to go either. She's my queen, bro.
>> She's my smoking buddy. >> Wes just wants them
all to drop off cuz it gets him closer to the the thing.
>> no, no, no, no, no. Wes does not care about making the
money anymore. You Wes off. Wes just wants to with your [__]
now. Wes's only goal is to make Sam look like a an idiot and
to like crater his [__] as much as possible. That's
if if you think Wes has any other motive at this point, you're
insane. >> Shut up at your door. the measuring. >> Are
you kidding?
>> No. I I think Wes knows that there's not going to be
a W here. I think when Sam started talking about, oh, I'm going
to do a reset and kick all these people out and not pay anybody.
I think Wes was I think Wes knew it was over. Okay.
>> Four people,
>> bro. What has today been? Holy
Joe. Four people
>> and we have a replacement. That means five people have
lost 5 days. There's two people. >> Five people in 5 days
free today.
>> He's trying. He doesn't have any people,
>> Go to the right and start screaming.
A fat [__]
>> You missed it. That was from
when Queen >> Oh yeah, that was a coort.
>> Just so you guys know, I don't want you to be up here
hungry and [__] It's just I've got to deal with the
drama. >> I don't want you to be [__] up here
and [__] It's just I've got to deal with the drama.
>> Okay. Can you bring us food?
>> Can you have one of the security guys bring us something
up? >> Your TTS for Kick House is I'd like to speak to
the manager. Someone just said >> bring some pizza.
>> Bring us a babe. A pizza.
>> We deserve chicken.
>> Big Brother 27 has been 100 times better than this for
a month straight. I've never watched Big Brother before. I I'll
be honest. I don't really get fish tank that much either, but
I get it if you're like watching with a group. I can see it being
fun watching with a group. For me personally, like by myself,
not any good. Whereas Peggy, is she peeing? Hopefully. Hopefully
she's found the >> We deserve
too. He's my friend.
>> Wes just goes to the bathroom.
slow down. >> YouTube comment says Sam Pepper was on bigger
brother Big Brother when he was super young. I think it's real.
and get >> No, there was a soup yesterday though. >> I
know.
I know. Yeah, >> I don't want her to. >> I know,
buddy. Me neither. We're all sucking up our month.
Every person >> I knew Andrew Tank was. >> What the
[__] >> She made all these buns. >> I
know what the whole [__]
>> Sam, I have a clip of you for about Wes. Please do watch
it.
Oh, come on. Why is this deleted?
Wes spreading hatred against who? Why did this get deleted, dude?
What was this?
Oh, [__] you.
Too bad.
Oh my god. >> We got no queen. Got no poking buddies. We
got no [__] chef. >> That's definitely just
going to be West [__] talking, right?
>> You don't have as much of a psycho [__]
>> Oh, they don't let me be psycho [__] >> They
[__] block your psycho. This is not >> Yeah,
but they let her be type of [__] That's not fair.
I can't even be the main crush up. >> No, you can be the
main crusher.
>> Well, Blue's here. No one's to save you. So, like no
one's going to keep you from crashing out. You're just like,
"Dude, start crashing out." >> I'm just going to start
crashing
all day, too.
>> I got nice T. Okay. People love nice. >> Oh, bring
Dude. Dude, Duke. >> Oh, was saying [__] on
a drunken rant. Okay. Yeah, dog. >> Okay, here's Blondie
leaving.
>> What? One one gal is is uh being confirmed. Um so I
need to get two more girls and one more guy. No, two more girls,
right? Yeah, two more girls and then we're back. Yeah, two more
girls. Yeah, then we're back up. Yeah, Lupa walked out.
>> The event ended. >> It's very strange that Lupa
just left. Like Loopa leaving was really strange. >> What
didn't he say? Hey, why don't you just go pack your He's trying
to fill the house back up. He's trying to get more replacements
for everybody.
a piece of dopamine.
>> M's saying that like Merk's saying that she didn't leave.
>> She's saying that I was told if there's going to be
a fight and you're scared, you should go to the other side of
the curtain. And then when when when then I can deal with the
situation.
>> M wasn't going to >> call Mike into the diary
room to check on where his head's at. >> Yeah. Yeah, we'll
talk to him. But M wasn't going to get in a fight. Like M got
upset and she left. Like M was going to be She said to me, "Yeah,
I had to go so I stopped myself from beating her ass." I said,
"Well, that doesn't it doesn't work like that as if you're scared
that you're going to get attacked." Um, so I I I understand like
I completely understand why she left. It makes complete sense.
Like that was I understand why she left, but that's not the situation
I
>> Oh, yeah. This meth meth cook and he tried to run me
down with >> Yeah, I don't care. >> Mike Smalls entering
the professional. >> You're not going to be able to handle
it, by the way. Um, how you feeling about everything? I see you
pacing around in that room and like, yeah, like how are you feeling
about everything that's going on inside the house?
>> That's the thing. It's like I know it's going to be
drama, but it's like, you know, 5 days in, bro. Um, and like
damn near the whole cast is gone. And it's
what the, you know what I mean? And it's like, I understand from
from your perspective, you're like, okay, you
you're you're put in an awkward weird position like, okay, so
I replace people. And I also feel like it's kind of not fair
for like people, you know, that was here from day one. I said,
"How can you make this shit?" It's just I don't know. It's like
it's it's
I don't know. Is this the Yes, this is Mike Smalls Jr. He's the
guy who's in the hurricane. More famously way better content
than the hurricane was when he tried to spend the night in Walmart.
Okay, that was compelling content. Mike Smalls hiding in the
dog food aisle of the Walmart after hours.
As much as I don't usually like
criminal like criminal behavior is content. Okay, that was some
funny.
This guy hiding in Walmart trying to find like the cup trying
to get the cup. All right, that was good [__] Yeah,
like the replacements that the replacements that come in, they
like they don't have like a better advantage of you or than you
guys or worse because they they still have to go through the
same amount like they're going to have to get they're going to
have to get a lot more votes than you guys. Like it's kind of
equal playing field anyone that joins um
>> But but so like what how is it going to be harder? because
you guys have already gone through one voting round, right? Tomorrow's
the next voting round. So, it's points that they've lost out
on that they could have got. So, they're going to have to get
more. So, so there's one one new contestant joining today and
then >> So, basically, someone can just What is the cut
off? >> Yeah, there's obviously three [__]
>> Obviously. Okay. Okay. Yeah, I think that um
I think that we'll we'll we'll fill it. We'll fill it. We'll
fill it probably up till >> Sam's got no idea what he's
talking about. Even Sam's just like making up as he goes. Dude,
the chatter's got it here. Okay, you might not be able to see
the chatter. Just says scam logic. Yes,
dude. It's We'll fill it up to two weeks remaining. We'll fill
it up to halfway
>> Oh crap. >> Because
if you're in the house two weeks, you're going to st you're going
to go the the distance. You know what I'm saying? So, we'll fill
it up to about 2 weeks so that like it it doesn't get too crazy.
But there's four of you in the house right now. Like, you want
it to the cast to just be you four for the next like uh three
and a three in a bit weeks cuz I don't I I think for you guys
it's not I mean for the money like for the money, yeah, maybe.
But it's going to be pretty boring. I mean, I can do that, but
>> I don't think it's it's going to be easier for me cuz
it's just you. But >> can I be real? Can I be real? Did
Willie Mack just go watch like some highlights of my stream or
Queman's stream and now he's just posting on Twitter? I What
is this tweet? I didn't see this tweet earlier. We have to let
Destiny keep on his computer without critical thought. Donald
Trump is president. He's not even doing the talking point correctly.
Is fascism is on the rise, guys. Fascism is on the rise. They're
saying if you think this, you're probably voted. You probably
Trump voter.
Didn't even spell Donald correctly. Well, he's doing his very
best. his best and we are very proud. Donald Trump, I think it's
a joke. Yes, it's the it's the joke that like guys, don't you
know there's a dang cheeto in the White House? Uh, what do we
of course we got to let Desi keep the There's a dang cheeto in
the White House. It's that Yeah, he's trying to do that. He's
like not doing it well. He like he's he saw us doing it and he's
like trying to do it his best. I think he honest to God came
out of this looking worse than the guy accused of being a and
possessor. Didn't even think that was possible.
That isn't possible. It literally isn't possible.
Okay. I think Willy's a complete,
but how in the world can you think that he looks worse than the
guy who basically admitted to having in his possession? I Huh.
And my proof of this is some YouTube comments. Okay. Regardless
of whether Willie back was right to report Destiny or not, I
think we can all agree that him recording the phone call and
uploading to YouTube for views is a bit tacky.
Yes, I would rather Okay, there's between not saying
and if he let's say there's a false there's I'm going to create
a false uh dichotomy for you. Okay, let's say the two choices
were not saying anything and reporting it but uploading the call
to YouTube. From William Ax point of view, if you have no other
information, obviously we choose uploading the video to YouTube.
Okay, he looked so dejected during that call like he was reporting
his own. He also looked like he was seeing God in different moments.
Okay, that like look upwards towards the light, right? Am I crazy?
Let me just see. I think I think Cherry tweeted this with some
appropriate music. Hold on. Some appropriate filters. Appropriate
music. It's here somewhere. There it is.
>> Let's find the Willy Willy Mac. Finding God in the middle
of this.
>> Why do you give me your Oh, Lord. Lord, why do you give
me your toughest
Why do you give me your toughest
DM
L Lord, why? Why do you do this to me?
But as much as I like to goof on Willy Mack, the idea that he
could somehow because of this phone call be worse than Desty,
the guy who is possessing the actual child abuse materials. I'm
sorry, I don't see it. And trust me, I have a PhD
in hating this. Okay,
I got a PhD and I can't see it. I can't divine a way to think
Willie Mack is worse than Destiny. Okay,
Willie. Whatever credibility you might have had just went poof.
I'm sure the police are very happy with you, too. Sharing possible
criminal evidence announcing I It's a little weird. Yeah. Yeah.
I It's more than a little weird, but
the worst part isn't the child. It's the fact he documented going
to the police. Only be going to the police like right away. But
this is obviously like a point. Someone from the same area because
of the leaks. Willie M is Oh well, okay. He's from a well-off
area. Sure. Don't talk about where he is. Don't say anything
further than that. That's fine, but don't say anything further.
Okay. Willy on a screenshot with Destiny going through 3TB of
Destiny's normal to prove he doesn't have on his computer. Okay.
All right, dude. What is this guy's endgame? What is this guy's
endgame?
What is this guy's endgame? What is this guy? What are these
guys even posting? I don't understand anything that's happening
anymore. What is this tweet? You're just repeating this. What
is this guy's endgame? What is this guy's Is there a joke here?
Can I get Can I get Deeperama on this to figure out what these
tweets mean? We get some we get some Deeperama wisdom on this
one. I feel like he could I feel like you could divine the meaning
of Nicholas Dioro here. Okay. Okay. All right. Hold on. We uh
we're we're making our way through >> Good content for
the viewers. >> I'm not trying to make it more I'm not
trying to make it more complicated for me either. I mean I feel
like I understand what you're saying. Okay. Yeah, that's going
to be hard for them to get bulls, but still it's just, you know,
the fact that me and Wes and whatever we put, it's like uh it's
like mentally detaching. So, even they're coming in fresh and
you know what I'm saying? Going through all this is already a
lot. You know what I mean? So, regardless of votes or free, it's
hard. It's still it's like >> I have to rebuild relationships
and all this [__] for everyone that pulls up and
leaves like what the dude. Um, so
I feel like personally if someone come walks us in here a week
and a half after I've been through all this handshit. >> So
one to I realize you've been like absolutely seething in chat
for like the past hour about us watching the kick house stuff.
Uh, we're watching the kick house stuff and then I'm going to
sleep. So I'm sorry if you thought or had an impression that
we're going to go back and watch that tonight. We're not. I made
it pretty clear that I'm take I'm taking this money. I'm going
to cover this content and then I'm going to bed.
I did. Did Did you get the impression we're going to go cover
that? Cuz it it wasn't happening. You've just sat here like seething
about us watching Kick House for like an hour.
Are you good? >> They shouldn't even have a a shot at the
prize. What the Unless like I don't know. Unless they're so amazing
to Okay. All right. Cool. All right. This person's saucy as you
know. Like >> Yeah. Yeah. No, I feel you. Um,
so that what they just be coming in the but the problem is is
if they're in the house without any insight of the prize then
they don't have like any benefit in like following the rules
or um you know what I'm saying like that. So we have we're going
to have to have a cut off point like you said like we can't inject
people in like the last week or you know even the last two weeks
to make it more >> Sorry I'm starting to skip around cuz
uh I know at this point
things are things are headed downhill fast. Okay. And we've got
4K angles of it. Hey, later or not in that room or something.
You guys are hanging out in boxes.
This is the new challenge. Hang out in boxes.
Wow. And kick just crashed on me or Yeah, kick just crashed on
me. Hold on.
This player just crashed for some reason. It should work.
Four hours
film, man.
I don't know why that happened, but we're good. Imagine,
>> please crack your skull open is a crazy thing to type.
>> I don't support that. >> There you go.
>> And then >> Wes is just reinforcing his box. It
looks like >> and you can be completely inside it, but
you you'll just be a box. Do you know what I'm saying? Yeah.
Like this.
And they can walk upstairs.
>> Tell me when I should turn chat on.
>> Tell me when I should turn chat.
>> I can say the [__] I want.
>> So Wes basically gets up. He says the box is stupid.
I'm out.
Box dumb. I'm out. Wes leaves and then I'm not sure >> I
love you gang.
But you got to take the L and end this [__] now or
change it to like 10 or 14 days max. >> You're not going
to fly out people every one day. You got to stop this comedy
now. Just take the L. >> No, I'm I'm happy to fly people
out. Like I'll just keep flying them out. That's kind of content
in itself. Like who's going to be the new streamer?
Who's going to be like the new one in the house?
I mean, why not?
I've I've got I've got everything set up for a month, so I'll
keep running it for a month. I I mean, I don't care to you know,
my DMs are only messages of people
>> I didn't want Peggy to walk in to go and get in the
rain, so she ordered it >> in to go and get in the rain.
So, she ordered it. >> You had no problem pushing her yesterday,
like fighting with her, but you don't want her to go walk in
the rain. Shut up, please. She's working for you. She's being
paid. >> All right, then leave, Les. What the [__]
is the point of an employee?
>> He has the cigarettes. He lost his >> [__]
you. >> He's lost his lighter. He has the cigarettes. He
lost his lighter. That's what he's mad about. >> The best
part about me walking out, Sam,
is that you've been a piece of trying to me over the whole time.
And I've destroyed you and dominated you. And my final you is
the last bastion of God that you have in this house. What was
holding it all together is about to walk out your door. And you're
get maybe get someone good. But if you pick the best eight and
you're going to place like PY that guy, what does he do? He won't
even >> Py has been some of the best content for the last
few days.
>> I have not seen a single Sam Pandy like uh clip this
whole time. >> The best story. >> I don't know what
this cope is. I've not seen a single clip from this guy. What
do you mean he's been the best content? You tell me your replacements
are going to be better than your [__] originals?
>> [__] you. No shot. >> That's the guy
who's massaging Merc. Oh, sorry. We did see the mercur clip of
her getting a massage. >> I know the west arc. It's just
going to be him on the event from the outside for like the next
two weeks.
That's going to be his content.
>> I left knew it was going to scam. He scams Mike [__]
>> He can't cover his traps. He knows what he does. He
knows he's [__] out. What an idiot.
We have Eli coming.
Eli's coming to meet us. Uh, I'm going to show him around this
area. This is called
Welcome to Thailand. Got some
challenges with no real [__] content except for a
crack and we're losing our [__] mind. Invite Mike.
I I uh follow him on Instagram, but he didn't accept yet. So,
if you guys see him live,
message him playing sale.
Guys, I know Mike's mad because of the whole thing, but truly
he has no ground to stand on. The deal was for 30 days. I knew
if you didn't say 30 days, you weren't going to get anything.
And I knew the show wasn't going to learn 30 days. My Pat Pongo
ner cowboy really. You cannot take a camera inside Nana Plaza
at all. Okay, so there you go.
This is uh this is Wes just talking. I don't want to get too
far into this because I don't want too many spoilers, but but
but but but trust me, there's almost there's almost nothing else
for the rest of this. Basically, everybody else leaves. Okay,
everybody else leaves. Wes Wes walks out and everyone's like,
"Oh, [__] this." They're all out, okay? Over a period
of like two hours or something. I didn't see a single clip of
it, including in clip compilations. So, I'm guessing it's pretty
boring. There's not a lot a whole lot there's not a whole lot
of like interesting [__] going on. But the end of
the the everything is Mike being the last one left in the house
and then he goes to talk to Sam
and Sam,
you know, as we've seen Sam is kind of full of >> just
gradually trying to fill it with more people as quickly as I
can. It's going to be >> So Sam's saying I don't want to
fill this with more people. I think I think we just end it, guys.
>> Hell yeah. That's what I'm saying. So it's like the
margin for error is way too high with that. Yeah, >> it's
just >> and like Yeah, it's like I'm going to be getting
people in and as I'm getting people in, people are fed up of
waiting for people in, they're going to leave, too. So, it just
doesn't make sense to do it this way. Like, if we're going to
do like, you know, if the event's going to continue, it needs
to continue like I don't know. It needs to continue fresh start
or or with a with a different kind of concept. And like I don't
want to like I don't want to
I don't want to keep you in the I
you know if it wasn't you in the house and there was just like
a bunch of like you know whatever. I I wouldn't really care.
But like I don't want to keep you in the house away from like
what you can do when I'm working out what I can do and I don't
think it's fair. It's not fair on you.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's it's just simply not not feasible for
me. Like as simple as that. And and I know you I know you're
gonna go out and make banging content anyway. And I hope one
second. Peggy's calling me.
>> No way. >> She cuts some off in the middle. Peggy's
calling me. Hold on. You're going to make banger content, though.
Don't worry, Mike. You're going to make banger content. It's
not going to be a problem that you're not here anymore. >> Someone's
calling him. So, I'm just I'm on hold. So, >> sorry. Nellie's
asking for her contract right now, and she won't leave the house
until she gets it. Jesus Christ. One
>> No, you chat is what
>> is
Chad is what I think about to happen about to happen.
>> Mike senses it. Okay, Mike is sensing it. Mike's the
hair is standing back up on the back of his neck. He's He feels
it like a lightning strike. Okay, Sam Pepper about to do what
Sam Pepper does. Mike can feel it coming. >> I'm like to
crash the VR this whole five days, I haven't crashed once.
We will see the situation, you know. >> Oh, sorry. Sorry.
Yeah. So,
>> I mean, it is it is what it is. Like, >> this
is what he's doing, McGee. >> I mean, I I don't know. I
feel I feel like a I feel like a I do feel like a you that's
it. And that's something that I'm not going to not feel, but
I feel like a
>> So So, what are you trying to say? Like, just just be
upfront, but >> I mean, we're
going to have to call it, >> Yeah.
So,
Call it, go home. Like, you know what I'm saying? >> Yeah.
I mean, like, you're a free man. Call it, go home. Are you talking
about, dude? Bottom line. Give me the bottom
>> I mean, I guess I mean, I guess I guess Mike, technically,
you're the winner. >> Technically, I'm the winner. >> I
mean, you're the one that lasts the longest. Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, hold up.
>> I mean, bro, you want to stay? >> Okay, let's
just be upfront about it. Basically what you're saying that um
>> it's really hot. Wait, let me turn my AC on. It's getting
hot in this room. >> Is it Is it hot in here? Is anybody
else know? Did they turn the thermostat up in here or
>> so basically you're saying the event's
>> Prize is over. Everything's clear.
>> I mean
the Yeah, the prize fund was like my payment if the event last
30 days.
You know what I'll do? This is what I'll do. [__]
tape. The problem. Yeah, I
>> No, I I can I mean I I I got I got an
>> You got an idea? Is the idea of paying him what you
owe him? >> How about like
I can give you like a shout out on my stream or something? Like
I can give you two hosts. >> Okay, this is trolling, right?
This has to just be trolling. Listen, man. I'll give you a sh
I'll give you like two hosts.
I know you're entitled to like 45k or something, but like I'll
give you two hosts. Cool. Two hosts and we're good. We're good.
Two hosts and we're good. Or
>> so you're saying in exchange for the cash prize, you're
going to want to give me a shout out on your stream and two hosts
on kick.com. >> Free hosts and I'll I'll
Mike Mike is the greatest streamer that's ever existed for free
streams as
Wow.
And I'll have 10. That's Oh my god. >> I'll have Peggy
tattoo me saying
offer if you Well, no. Um I don't want your raggy host. Um so
you better get this right or I or I [__] Peggy. So
I got that I got that bit from Wes. Shout out Wes. >> And
you've got four bedrooms to choose from as well.
>> All right. Let me Should I let Peggy know now or? >> No,
but I don't want you there. I'm just kidding. No, but um >> you
know, yeah, like I said, like I told you what I told you I'm
happy to give you something earlier when we talked on stream
and I I'll still be happy to give that to you. I know it's it's
not it's not 40k or whatever's left, but >> but like something
like I mean like bro here the thing I know like bro dead ass.
You know what I'm saying? You got to be fair like bro just keep
it a buck. What am I going home with? You know what I'm >> Okay,
this is what I think you're going home with to be honest with
you. Okay, I think you're going home. >> It sounded like
he was a little excited about it. It's like, which room do you
want to which room do you want to do that in? I got cameras in
every room, Mike. I I got cameras everywhere >> with a
great experience to tell your future kids. Okay.
>> You're you're in you're in Asia, which you can travel
around and make great IRL content. Okay.
And also
me and you, >> if these guys weren't, they would band together
and basically go across like Bangkok right now having a blowout
Sam Pepper this scamming party, right?
They go, they break into his house, they'd steal one of his credit
cards and they'd max that [__] out in Bangkok. Okay,
that would be incredible content. finally get to me and
like you can call me your friend now. >> So Asia,
you're my friend. Future members for that. That's >> the
first time a black man was stiffed by Sam. Uh you're not sending
me gay, are you? >> I went hard on this fictional because
>> it's the only b left. Can't drink. I can't smoke. I
can't gamble. >> As Bert continues his confessional, the
RV hits rocky terrain and starts to shake uncontrollably.
What? >> He stops and production tells Bert to go >> All
right, Bert, you hop out. >> They all walk in the middle
of the desert and we see production with a large check.
>> You have won season three. >> Bert wins first
place with a grand prize of $0 since they lost it all gambling
from yesterday. Production walks off as Bert stands motionless
with a worthless check. They drive off and leave Bert alone in
the desert, officially ending season 3. Will they actually build
a spaceship for season 4? >> In reality, you got 15K.
>> Wait, Mike or Bird? >> Bro, bro, I'm like I'm
I'm
like I said to you, I'm already 30K in a hole right now. >> You're
$30,000 in a hole. >> I feel for you, bro. >> Who
the [__]
It's my fault. You [__] >> Oh, for [__]
sake. Why you? Out of everyone.
Out of everyone. Why you?
I just anyone else. I would just I wouldn't even talk to them.
I wouldn't even address them. I would say, "Okay, like the stream's
over. Just stay there. Here comes your grab." But Mike, bro,
it hurts me. It really >> Who believes Sam at this point?
It hurts him to scam somebody. No shot. >> Really hurts
me. Is he being stupid? >> Wait, was Sam when Sam was Sam
I know it was the Faze guys. Was Sam involved in Save the Kids
Coin or was it just the Was it Was it just the Faze people? He
didn't do like
he didn't do like
fake charity for little kids, right? Yes, it was Sam. Okay. So,
so when he says he feels bad, he was the ring leader. So, when
he says he feels bad,
he doesn't feel bad. Okay. He doesn't feel bad. >> Yeah.
Listen, man. They're all spamming pay Mike $50,000,
$30,000. S scam pepper strikes again. Typical white guy. >> Okay,
let's just be real.
Maybe not 50k,
but like you is 50k after 30 days. You went 5 days. Take the
50k, divide it by six, maybe divide it by, I don't know, 10 10k.
10k.
Let this guy hold 10k. Okay, let him hold 10k
and just be like, you know what? I didn't I didn't totally scam
him. He made 10k off the KCIP. Let's be real. You totally made
the
$30,000. S scam pepper strikes again. Typical
white guy taking advantage of the black guy. Huh?
>> And you don't feel any any level of I mean, listen,
you said I like your mind. You are great. >> Sam made it
seem like he lost money on the event. It was their fault. Well,
he might have lost money in the event. It's possible, right?
The the prize was planned to be 30K after all the deductions.
Yeah, well, Sam's a [__] loser. That's such a stupid
way to run something. Is that how Big Brother works? They deduct
money from the prize pool. That's like the lamest, most counterproductive
way to run a like anything. You deduct money
That's so stupid.
>> Great guy, [__] [__] that. It's
the [__] principal. I pull up to the event. Last
one standing. I got to deal with these [__] tweakers,
[__] They want a [__] orgy. [__]
your orgy, [__] It's just pissing me the [__]
off. All right. I think I earned something, [__]
Let's give it a buck. >> One buck. Yeah. Yeah, I got you.
One
>> One buck, one. >> All right. Okay. What about
this, Mike? >> I would take the two streambot raids. Personally,
dude, the bots don't even stick around. You get raided 5K. 5K
viewers from Sam Pepper. After 2 minutes, you've got 200 viewers.
The purpose of that raid. >> You want to do a gambling
stream tonight and it's all your money. Like you you can I I
don't know if you're down with that or not, but you it's you
3,000
>> Hey, hey, hey. Horse boy. Horseman. Listen, I don't
gamble.
>> Yeah, I know. I know. Okay. All right. All right. Okay.
What about this? Would you take gambling winnings?
>> What is he saying? What is he saying? Is Sam like, "Listen,
how about I put 5K into Plinko and if I hit a like a a 26x then
I'll give you the money
yourself, Sam, in a video game." Okay. >> I just said I
don't get No. >> No. If I gamble and you get >> He's
literally saying it. This
>> I win tonight. That's this.
>> you're not here. You're not with me. I'll just do it
and then whatever I win, I give to you.
>> I listen. Say the gambling word again. It's going to
really piss me off. I don't I don't want to be associated with
gambling. Okay. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No gambling. Nothing
to do with gambling. Nothing too >> No big dog. PTSD off
this [__] You feel what I'm saying? Got to be real,
bro. Deep down in your heart somewhere, you know what the right
thing to do is. But your pride's in the way. Just spit it out.
Maybe not pride, but maybe so. I don't know. Yo, Peggy, can you
get the security in to the diary room, please?
>> I don't think he's getting
>> Are they Is he just going to escort Mike out? He's going
to be like, "Escort this. Escort this out. >> Get him out
of here." No way. Right.
>> I'll wait, man. I'll wait. >> Where's everyone
else gone? >> Stop being around the bush. Let's just Let's
stay on topic here. Try and deflect here. Just stay on topic.
>> What do you Okay, tell me what you want. How about Don't
Don't be showing me like that. How? What do you want, Mike? What
do you want? >> I want the cash prize.
I don't even take a little bit. A little bit less than now. [__]
A >> little bit less. >> Those are my hands. >> All right.
I'm booking your hotel right now for you for tonight and I'll
make sure it's nice. That's a start, right? That's a start. >> Okay.
Going to book me a hotel. >> That's a start. I'm I'm on
my phone currently right now and I'm book >> How did he
not say, "Okay, you're booking me a hotel. Peggy's going to be
there for the night." Okay. Make him agree to that, Mike. Make
him agree. >> Okay, that's a start, right? But but here's
the thing, and y'all you know me, I'm a fair guy, right? right,
All you're going to look at me. I cannot leave this crib until
I know what the full offer is. And I know it's crazy to say you
have to went through a lot. I understand that. But like, come
on, dude. You can't just go through all these mental gymnastics
talking about, can I get you? Gez, what the [__]
you talking about, [__] Like, look, bro. Come on,
bro. You know what I'm saying? You got to level with me here.
I I think I deserve an answer by the time I leave this. >> And
let me let me get your hotel done first and then I'll think.
Hm. I was thinking like
Okay. How about How about like like $750?
>> $750. So much give it up. No.
>> Uh, [__] Wait. Um, I'm booking you the nicest
room as well. Like it's it's Oh, it already had all your information
in there. Nice. Okay. Yeah, I'm >> jacuzzi. I'm I'm ordering
a bill and room service and all. >> Yes. Yes. I'll order
you like any food you want to the house as well. All right. I
>> Oh, you think this is what it was that if he You think
there was basically like stipulations in the contract that say
as long as he stays in the house, he gets the money? >> Okay.
I'll >> Oh, boy. I'll give you I'll give I'll give I $2,000,000
>> then I'm
$2,000 down. >> Wait, I made I made a little Wait, I made
I made I'll be like I'll be like
$5,000 down
>> $2,000 $2,000.
>> No, it's not my audio that's it's Sam's audio that's
fuckous.
This only been five, right? Uh, but come on, dude.
>> Sam said there's a line in the contract stating he doesn't
need to pay the
>> How much How much do you normally make would you say?
>> Don't worry. Don't worry about my cheese. Okay. That's
irrelevant. It's about the principal, right? I'm only 5 days.
I understand that. But you know, I don't deserve you the full
40. Look. >> No, but the 40,000 disappears. Like the moment
you walk out the door, the 40,000 disappears. You understand
that, right? >> My uh Mike should have just been like,
"Oh, it's fine. Fill it back up. I'll be here. Fill it back up.
>> So, like it's it's just my money, which is fine, which
is fine. It's my money. >> Okay. So, you said 2,000. Can
we Can we I said 15 10. >> Oh. Oh, wait. We're doing a
negotiation.
>> I mean, you start. >> Can I start again? Can I
start again at 1 and then you say 10? And then I say two and
then you say, "Okay." Go, dude. At this point, bro, I tried my
best, but it just means at this point.
I mean, whatever.
So, what kind of speech is that? I I'm trying to be brutally
honest. I ain't think you're going to do me like that.
There's no way you going to do me like that doing me like that.
I'm like, "Yo, dog."
[__] Uh, yeah. I don't really know what to say. It's
like, you know what the problem is? Is ice Poseidon. It's his
This is the worst part. This is the worst cope I've ever heard
in my life. Okay, just get ready for this. It's actually Ice
Pesign's fault. Paul Paul is just too generous. Paul is just
too >> because, bro, he's always giving these runners up
like, "Oh, here's $250,000
for being a runner up." Like, it's his problem. He's too He has
too much money and he makes all the rest of us look like we're
scamming when we're like, "Oh, get >> when when we just
lie and and totally lie about the prize." He makes the rest of
us look like scammers. >> You know, do your stream like
get your flight here. Get a nice hotel. A really nice hotel.
Got a nice one for you. Get a nice hotel. And also here's 2K
as well. Like
listen, you're riding about ice beside and that [__]
should have nothing to do with anything with you. You already
comparing ice. Hey, he's in his lane. You're in yours. Uh being
on a bus here, Sam. Okay. Got a hotel on the floor. Um we got
to talk about, you know what I'm saying? What really matters?
What do you feel like I truly earned and deserved after everything
I've been through?
>> Evil comment. Evil Johnny Bravo. There's
>> I think you I think you've earned like
>> I think you've earned like $2,500.
>> Come on, Mike. >> You think I've earned $2,500?
Yes or no? >> Yeah, my whole my whole chat is literally
spamming like that's
super fair.
>> Uh-huh. That's super fair. The entire chat 10k is fair.
10k is fair. 10k is fair. 5k 10k. 5k or 10k. 10k is fair. Pay
at least 10k. That's my chat. A lot of my chat saying like that's
actually nice of you to to give him that, Sam.
Literally, he knows he's meing. He knows he's meing right now.
>> Let me check to see if we can't right >> Wait,
Rebel, you know this is wrong, right? You know, Sam Pepper's
probably got at least
at least a million dollars in crypto, if not more.
Like, he absolutely has the money. He He might have to pay people
in crypto, but he could absolutely pay people like a million
bucks in crypto. 100% chance, right? 100% chance. He is just
totally full of [__] He's just a greedy piece of
[__] Realizes he doesn't have to pay people. He absolutely
has the money right now. When he tells you he doesn't have the
money to he's probably got it in cash just from streaming on
kick so >> So you think that's fair in Sam's chat? Yes
or no? >> All right, I'm gonna have to deduct. >> Oh,
let people do kick. I see it. I see. I see what you're saying.
>> [__] [__] you. Sounds like people
are saying no in the chat. >> No, it's it's hard to tell
though. Like it might look like no for you, but cuz it's moving
really fast. Like the things blur blur blur together a little
bit. >> Just just gaslight. Let's go. Oh, the the letters
blur together and it's like hard to distinguish what word one's
>> Look, if you take the remaining matter, it's $4,000.
You divide it by 30 days, right? Just $4,000. You divide by No,
30 days. Okay, that's $1,333.
You times that by 5 days I've been here, that's $6,66 fucking6.
That's just the baseline I feel I deserve. >> Yeah, that
is the baseline. >> That's just the bas including all the
Um, am I right? Am I right? >> You know what? I think it's
probably best like if we sleep on this a little bit, we can buy
>> It's probably best if you just get the [__]
off that property I'm renting and uh yeah, we'll figure it out.
>> Make a clear decision on what's right and like >> uh
I feel like you're trying the easy way out. Um honestly, you're
under a lot of pressure today, but you don't want to be out cheese.
Um but respectfully, I'm not trying to sleep on [__]
I want people to sleep like without knowing what the [__]
I just agreed to.
>> Hey, Mike. Um, so yeah, your car the your car's Yeah,
your car's pulling up right now. Like um and I got it going straight
to the hotel for you. So yeah. Um,
no, I appreci I really do appreciate you, Mike. And it was like
a super It was super fun. Like uh >> car is pulling up
now. I know you said you weren't leaving until I said what I
was going to pay you, but uh you know the car's pulling up. You
got to go.
>> Having you here. Thank you. Thank No, really. Like I'm
glad we're still boys after all of this.
Just send me your your Bitcoin wallet and I'll I'll deposit >> deposit
what >> the funds. >> How much? >> How much?
>> Can you wait like a little bit of time for Bitcoin to
go back up? It's like on like a 6% dip right now.
>> Oh. Oh. Bitcoin's down a little bit. So wait a little
bit because Bitcoin's down. Uh
>> yeah. Yeah. It's pretty It's looking It's Yeah, things
are down right now. So it's a little bit of bad time. You can
just give me a week or >> Sam is just trolling right now
>> this week. If you give me a week or something to like
>> I ain't going to lie. You got to play the high IQ move
here, right? You know what I'm saying? You're literally scanning
in real time live on kick. Look, man. It's not going to make
it's not going to be good face for you. Let's be honest, right?
Um deep down your heart, do the right thing and we'll be boys.
Let's just be real here. >> All right, then. I got you.
>> Say the amount, Sam.
>> So, we'll catch up again like whatever. You want to
do a stream together or something whilst you're here? I'm down.
>> Stream together?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I can take you to dinner or something. Take
you to one of my favorite spots. >> Bro, I'm not trying
to get off, bro. You got me
sound like some, bro. No, I don't want a date. What the Take
me on a >> No, thank you. >> Listen, at the end of
the day, bro, you
I'm getting for you not planning your event the right way. Okay,
at the end of the day, when it's all said and done, you are the
reason why this went left. It's not my fault, bro. So, yeah.
You got to take the L.
You know what I mean?
>> The thing is is not only have I got to answer to you
right now, the moment I hang up from you, I've got I've got everyone
else to answer to.
It's not a fun evening for me, Mike. Put it that way. So, like,
>> and it wasn't a fun evening for me or anybody in the
real >> think about it.
You and Sam Pandy hit house on road tonight. It's going to be
a movie.
[__] the movie. All right. I need I need the funds
to make the movie.
Oh, >> calling me. The car. Your car's here.
>> Your car's here. >> Cancel the car. Cancel it.
>> My phone's going to die as well. >> One second.
>> Sam's just going to like end the stream, isn't he? Sam's
just going to like >> Hey, man. My internet's dying. I
don't know what to do. >> Yeah, Mike. I've got to go shoes.
>> No way, dude. I swear to God, I didn't pre-watch that.
I swear to God, I could just tell he's like uncomfortable. He's
just I'm I'm going. I'm Bye. Bye. See you, dude.
>> Dude, no way. >> Say [__] sake. [__]
>> How is this living? >> Dwayne must be like, "What
the going
>> The way must be like, "What the Oh my god, bro. What
am I going to do?" Uh, >> there's guys. Uh,
>> all right. Uh, I'll be
>> It's the reason Sam is in a different country than the
house.
>> I'll be back. Uh,
I'll be back shortly, guys. I just need to take care of some
things. Um,
>> Thanks so much, guys. >> I think he does come
back. We'll watch.
>> we might be watching this tomorrow. Okay, he's he's
ending his stream, guys. It's uh it's about that time. We're
uh we're going to end here. Okay, I'm looking for who we're hosting.
I don't know, man. I'm I'm probably just beasting out. All right,
guys. That's it for the stream. That's Scam Pepper emerging again.
I heard and I don't know for sure, but I'd heard that Ice Poseidon,
we might cover this tomorrow if it exists. I heard Ice Poseidon
hopped on a stream, hopped on a call with him. I don't know if
that's real. I don't know if that's true, but if it did happen,
I'll find it for tomorrow. All right. Otherwise, guys, we'll
be back tomorrow. I think we're going to do more chorus stuff.
I'm going to be I'm going to be looking into this. This might
be a couple days. This is a topic. Okay. This is a topic. All
right. I love you guys. Have a good night. I'll be back tomorrow.
Tata for now. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.